[Music]
eriell gasps for breath as she washes up
on foreign land she coughs and checks
her mermaid tail it's gone and in its
place or legs she giggles and tries to
walk she struggles at first but is
kicking up sand in no time
Ariel's joy subsides when she realizes
that she doesn't know where she is
hello anyone help she begins her trip
inland to seek help her new legs begin
to tire in the distance she notices
something strange she tries to take
another step but her bare feet are sore
she falls to the ground instead is she
okay
I don't know Ariel Ariel yo it's me girl
wake up dude your feet are bare what are
you doing get up come on let us help you
back at Mullins temple Mulan Jasmine I
don't know what I would have done
without you guys I washed up on shore
and I didn't know where I was
yo girl like I said I'm a warrior
princess and we always find our girls
princesses stick together hon thank you
both
you saved me anything for a sister wow
this palace is beautiful how long have
you been here years and years but I
can't stand it I used to love it but the
guy next door has a crush on me and I
can't escape him in every corner I turn
there's all these fans who know me and
that are like Oh Mulan Mulan sign this
do that I could really use a break
Jasmine receives a text message Aladdin
is being such a baby we got into a fight
and he left off - I don't know where he
won't tell me boys tell me about it Erik
can be so moody he's always trying to
get me to eat fish I mean come on I know
I'm just getting worried he isn't
answering me back and when he does it's
just big messages about how I shouldn't
have let Abu eat all of the bananas well
let's go find him then what Mulan needs
out of this place and you're worried
about Aladdin
let's just take the magic carpet jasmine
and go find your prince
the princess is take-off on Jasmin's
glowing magic carpet it's a little tight
normally it's just me and my man whoa
there there girl you got this be a
warrior we're on a mission let's do this
the princess is soar through the clouds
as the temperature starts to drop is it
because I'm from Agrabah or did it just
get really cold no no it's definitely
getting cold yeah my toes oh wow my toes
I completely forgot how exciting but
they're getting really numb is that
normal not normal no you should feel
them for sure oh no the carpet is
beginning to tired it's not used to so
much weight we need to line now or else
we're going to crash Jasmine grabs the
edge of the fading carpet and directs it
downward in search of a place to land
wow it's beautiful Jasmine lands the
carpet in front of a glorious castle a
beautiful blond haired girl runs out the
castles front door who could it be who
is that she looks crazy
oh my god that's Elsa the Elsa from
frozen she's not a real Disney Princess
the three princesses gasp she's not no
blasphemy we can't interact with her
it's just not our style
you know girls Elsa gets closer she
waves and welcomes them princesses I'm
so excited that you finally accepted my
invitation to visit us in this wintry
Wonderland
welcome
we can have hot chocolate with
marshmallows and gossip about our
Suzette's Elsa it's a real pleasure this
is Jasmine and Ariel as you already know
we're actually looking for Jasmine's
lover who seems to have disappeared a
lot yes well she isn't here but you're
welcome to stay the night
there's a storm coming and it may not be
safe you three on that one small carpet
thank you so much for the offer but we
must continue on princesses stick
together oh well I am NOT a princess but
I tried my best - we need to find a
Latin his texts are getting weird and
I'm worried he better not be hanging out
with Sleeping Beauty again the carpet
seems to have had enough rest let's head
off fabulous ladies I really think it's
not safe please listen to me my parents
made this mistake once and the magic
carpet lifts off as the princesses
ignore Elsa what could possibly happen
to their small carpet during a storm bye
lovely kisses miss Elsa good luck with
Anna Elsa watches go worried for their
safety the princesses fly through the
sky we just do not hang out with non
princesses and that's that she seemed
nice enough though and what if she was
right no
our group is princesses only it's a rule
is it yes we're fine look no problems so
far smooth carpet flying just then
the carpet jerks and nosedives the three
princesses
as the carpet quickly recovers the
frightened princesses hold on for dear
life with a splash they land in the
middle of the ocean they cling on to the
tired magic carpet but the more they
hold on the more the carpet sinks danger
is upon them we can't all hold on the
carpet is thinking I need my fins Elsa
was right we're doomed
suddenly out of nowhere a wooden raft
breaks through the storm
a brave Hawaiian girl is taking on the
elements to save her fellow Disney kin
it's Moana grab on the princesses grab
on to the side of the raft Moana and
then saves the carpet with her or will
they make it back to shore the waves are
rough but Moana is determined they made
it the next morning they find themselves
on a sunny Hawaiian beach Thank You
Moana we owe you more than we could ever
give you yes thank you
that is the most scared I've ever been
in the ocean which is saying a lot for
me I'm just happy I saw you three
plummet down on that magic carpet
without a triple glow I'm not sure I
would have noticed it you made us
realize that you don't have to be a
princess to be a good person we were so
ignorant to everyone else around us we
ladies have to stick together and help
each other out no matter our differences
you hear me girls totally hon we hear
you yes for sure we should have listened
to Elsa she was right it was only
looking out for us
hey I have an idea what well the magic
carpet is recovered and there's no storm
in sight let's send it to pick up Elsa
oh my gosh yes yo girl that's the best
idea you've had yet
any word from Aladdin he's back in
Agrabah he just sent me a photo of him
and Jafar making funny faces so that I
wouldn't be mad at him Jafar yeah
believe it or not he's actually the
nicest guy you'll ever meet killer style
too he just plays the villain really
well wow so cool are these gonna hang
out for a while might as well you are in
Hawaiian paradise
after all Elsa finally arrives on the
magic carpet Elsa we are so sorry for
how we treated you lawanna made us
realize it doesn't matter if you're a
princess or not you're still chilled to
be our friend we just never thought that
non princesses were people like us
anyway
Ariel jasmine and I wanted to have you
join us in Milano for a weekend on this
glorious island what do you say girl do
you forgive us friends Elsa smiles and
hugs Mulan
yes friends I understand
differences can sometimes be scary and
they all lived happily ever after on the
beautiful island of Hawaii
let's just hope that there's no more
storms on the horizon the end
[Music]